la réglementation des repas six apart va
adorer ça vous avez quelqu'un qui vous
représente à paris le vénéré guardian
nous fait l'honneur de sa présence ce
sont les nouveaux words words hébert
style excuse moi partout pour trouver
une histoire qu'il fasse parler de lui
je devrai travailler pour cette heure la
vitesse où on vire les journalistes
reçus n'aura bientôt pas le choix tu
essayé de nous faire perdre notre boulot
je veux vous le fassiez correctement si
vous n'y arrivez pas un autre fera à
votre crise
et c'est ce que tu fais n'importe qui
peut balancer n'importe quoi sur le net
et dire que c'est de l'info mais les
gens achètent notre journal pour avoir
de vraies infos ya encore des gens qui
achètent votre journal vraiment je vous
en prie messieurs nous partageons les
mêmes idées celle du journalisme citoyen
c'est un nouveau système nerveux
tirailleurs de partout
et oui on a des mille visites par heure
pouvez vous en faire un temps mais au
fait comment se porte votre site ou fait